June is the one month out of the year
where we expect to catch a glimpse of
the future of gaming and sure enough
this year's Electronic Entertainment
Expo delivered loads of exciting
announcement but even though most of
those games won't be in our hands until
2015 it was still a great month thanks
to all the games released over the past
few weeks that kept our heads hands and
hearts busy 1001 spikes was an early
favorite with it's pixelated charm and
enjoyable but punishing platforming but
that same day we also got wildstar a
colorful massively multiplayer online
role-playing game stuffed with character
unusual things to do and interesting
places to see a week later a revamped
version of the sharp-looking blood of
the werewolf landed on the xbox 360 and
we were pulled in by it's monster-movie
law and Lacan throat field platforming
we were also drawn into the melancholy
valiant hearts the Great War which
presented the human side of armed
conflict and involuntary enlistments
which is so often ignored or emitted
from games that use war as an excuse for
gritty settings and unchecked brutality
as deserving of recognition as those
games are it was Yacht Club gazes shovel
Knight that ultimately won us over and
secure the award for game of the month
in June shovel Knight is a smart and
refined platformer that evokes the
spirit of some of the best nes games of
the late 80s and early 90s including the
likes of megaman Castlevania and duck
tales but this heavy dose of nostalgia
is just the icing on the cake shovel
Knight stands tall on its own merits
like Mega Man shovel Knight thrives on a
variety of enemies and
platforming challenges making it near
impossible to plow through levels your
first time through but shovel Knight is
a less punishing game than megaman ever
was numerous check points per level help
stave off the frustration of starting
from scratch when you inevitably meet
your doom of course if you've got
bravery and greed coursing through your
veins the checkpoints true through each
level can be destroyed for extra cash
paving the way for new upgrades and
greater feats of shuttle room likewise
ultimate treasure line paths stand out
beckoning for your trowel sting visually
shovel Knight is a feast for the eyes
yes it's low fire with an 8-bit lean and
the music is suitably chippy but you
could also characterize it as a game
filled with delightful art and a catchy
fast-paced soundtrack it may be easy to
point to the old-school qualities that
can be found in every element of shovel
Knight and call it a nostalgia grab but
that top level analysis ignores the fact
that even though it borrows from the
past it does many of the things that
seemingly emulates better than the
source material ever did despite what
our memories of the past would like us
to think still there's a reason we hold
those classics dear in our hearts and
minds and a reason shovel knight
deserves for commissions are standing up
to the caliber of its muses and then
some
you